and Simon just walk us through this
because we've had the statement from the
1922 committee the conservative
administrative body taught me through
what happens next now what and then
there was one what started as a race of
five has a lost boy jumps it early on
become that race 45 and now Andrea
libsyn has withdrawn smacks of house of
cards and other political thrillers but
it now looks like Theresa May will be
the the next prime minister of britain
and how soon it's something for the
Conservative Party to work out pretty
quickly I guess how the dominoes fall is
something like the Prime Minister goes
to the Queen issues a formal resignation
then a Conservative Party decide whether
to resume officially becomes the prime
minister from there Simon where do we go
next what have we learned from Theresa
May in the last two weeks as to how the
dominoes fall from here I think two
things firstly she's him to remember
about trees and Men and partly why
Andrea Ledson was running was that may
was a member of the remain campaign
ahead of that referendum she was quite a
quiet one she's been Euroskeptic for
quite a long time she made one speech in
the campaign so she was quite muted but
now and increasingly already throughout
the the campaign for to become Prime
Minister she's made the point that
brexit means brexit she's kind of been
bulking up her Euroskeptic view she
previously said that the article 50 we
now all know about wouldn't be triggered
this year she might come under pressure
for women a party to put a faster time
frame on that certainly she's going to
come under pressure from Europe to build
a kind of exit strategy that we don't
really have at the moment a plan for
getting out and secondly and he sort of
tasted this in the speech they she's
going to try according to speech to her
to broaden the conservative base away
from austerity which has been the
watchword of its manifesto since 2010
talking today about much much broader
policies things like a curbing executive
pay putting workers on board something
like the Labour Party in some in some
cases but looking to broaden the base
and make the economy one that more can
share from if she said this morning in
Birmingham Simon I would say this in
historic moment although it seems like
history's being made almost every day or
in the UK
when it comes to politics many of us
don't know Theresa May before this event
and we do know now that she was mildly
four remain what can you tell us about
her leadership thus far as Home
Secretary what her career has been like
what her husband like that would
indicate what she would be like as prime
minister because it appears she will be
at this really pivotal moment in UK
history yep she's been home secretary
for the last six years I think that
makes the longest-serving a Home
Secretary one who's been teased a an
algal ism from there the blaie is tough
on crime for the causes of crime very
tough on immigration something that will
appeal to the Euroskeptic so that's
really been her had had a mantra for the
last year's is reducing immigration
she's been tasked with doing so hasn't
done so particularly successfully
although perhaps not fully to blame for
that but certainly one of the key points
to being home secretary has been her
attempt to rein in immigration a theme
that was a was central to the brexit
campaign what are the chances that may
cause an early election well she's
previously said she wouldn't the
argument for doing so is that a general
lecture would be a chance to give her
her own legitimacy her own mandate it
could be argued there the Conservatives
11 under David Cameron a year ago that
policy is not particularly a off kilter
from what tho what was promised there
and that there's time for the government
to be focused on implementing brexit
rather than seeking the votes of the
British people but certainly one thing
that will come from this or they'll be
chatter out there is the fact that what
now looks like a coronation of Theresa
May may make more pressure on her to
call an early general election but again
you got to remember now we have fixed
terms bit like the United States we can
get around them a bit more easily than
that but currently there's no know what
elections scheduled to 2020 and so the
Labour Party's in crisis various things
on on that front so the idea will be
there but perhaps won't be enacted Simon
it's a dangerous game to take too much
signal away from an intraday bounce on
the back of this new use but it is a
stronger pound story very very
marginally do we just assume that the
market looks at this and says a little
bit less uncertainty
t around who the next prime minister
actually is that's a little bit of
relief we can move on but quite clearly
the message ahead is going to come from
the Bank of England this week what do we
expect the response to be what's shaping
up on Threadneedle Street so according
to the bloomberg survey economist the
majority expect the the bank to ease
interest rates this week they've been
some thought they might wait till August
doesn't really fit in with a mark
carney's kind of action man approach to
central banking so the betting is that
will see an interest rate cut this week
for your having of the 0.5 percent rate
and perhaps more on things like funding
for lending perhaps even some more QE
there's certainly the the central bank
has long warned that there would be
economic turbulence from brexit we are
seeing signs of that and perhaps type of
monetary policy to do its bit this week